don't know if i'd be happy or not i
can't make my mind up really um but
we've got two people here i suspect
we'll have a different view of what
decision would make them happy so i'm
joined now by the fox nation host tommy
lehrer and the author and
self-proclaimed moe marxist grace
blakely welcome to both of you grace let
me start with you
would it make you happy if donald trump
was to run again in 2024 well regardless
of whether or not it would make me happy
it seems as though that's what he's
gearing up to do my question is what is
he going to run on last time he manages
managed to build some vaguely popular
support by promising to drain the swamp
right
he then um was in office he dished out
millions to big corporations in his tax
cuts he deregulated the finance sector
which had caused the financial crisis
that had left so many americans in
poverty and out of their homes who is
going to believe this the only option he
has is to do what he did in your
interview is to just step up the culture
wars try and convince people that their
material interests don't matter that
inflation the what's going on with the
economy with skyrocketing corporate
profits and billionaire profits while
people go starving that that doesn't
matter that all that matters is uh you
know this culture war um silliness
around trans uh bathrooms and sports and
all these different sorts of things that
are aimed to distract us from the fact
that the people running these countries
do not care about the vast majority of
their citizens okay i think we'll take
that as an unhappy camper if trump wants
to run again tommy larry i presume you
would be a little happier you're a big
trump fan i know
well listen what we just heard there was
gaslighting 101 i mean the proof is in
the pudding when you talk about how well
our country did under the trump
administration and how poorly it's doing
now i mean you don't have to talk about
culture wars you don't have to talk
about right versus left you just look at
the statistics and you look how well our
country was performing under president
trump i'll tell you this i'm not sure if
he's going to run my personal uh
feelings of this is that it should be
ron desantis i think that if you have a
ronda sanders then you don't have to
listen to the dribble of the january 6th
and the big personality of donald trump
we can get right back to business having
an america first candidate like donald
trump but i'll tell you this my rescue
chihuahua would be a better choice than
what we have in office right now and
anybody that sits on that democrat bench
i mean tell me that
i'm gonna be tickled pink right i mean
for those who don't know ron desantis
he's the governor of florida he's
proving very popular he's involved in
what grace would categorize as a culture
war at the moment with disney i would
argue disney started that war themselves
but grace you know you're obviously
horrified by the thought of trump or
even trump like some people think
desantis is but here's the truth what uh
tommy just said about joe biden is
indisputable his presidency is turning
into a complete disaster and you on the
left surely have to accept unless he
gets his act together whoever wins the
republican nomination is highly likely
to win the yeah because the system is
broken the money in american politics is
corrupting the entire system look at
this senator joe manchin right that has
stood in the way of so much progressive
legislation being passed he is literally
in the pockets of the big fossil fuel
companies and you can say this but you
know lobbying in the capital is this
horrendous thing that distorts american
politics and prevents democracy that
doesn't change the fact yeah that was
why that was why trump did so well but
he didn't do anything about it but he
does nothing about it right but the
democrats have to find someone that
could win an election and whether it's
trump or desantis or whoever it may be
at the moment that train the democrat
train is crashing into the sightings you
have to admit that yeah i mean there is
clearly an absence of leadership right
and i think part of the reason that
there's an absence of leadership is
because
of this like swamp-like state of
washington like you know people who
really are standing up and fighting for
the rights of ordinary people people
like alexandria cortez people like
bernie sanders they are just destroyed
and eviscerated by a media by an entire
establishment that exists
that exists alexandra okay
we have to choose between someone like
biden
look alexander occasionally she dishes
it out like anybody i've ever seen up
there so it's not a one-way ticket tommy
i want to move just quickly on talk
about leadership to elon musk and his
purchase of twitter which is causing a
lot of headlines this week one of the
big questions he may face is about
twitter's apparent censorship of people
like donald trump where they allow
vladimir putin taliban leaders supreme
leader of iran to all have accounts but
they've actually banned a recently
departed president united states i find
that inconsistency ridiculous i'm only
sure trump would want to go back given
he's got his own platform now but what
do you think about musk what do you
think about twitter what do you think
about what should be happening here
oh i am cautiously optimistic this is
the shake-up that needed to happen elon
musk coming in to twitter was like
donald trump coming into the political
sphere and i think it's going to be
fantastic it remains to be seen if he
really is going to restore free speech
but we're talking about censorship it's
easy to see those that have been
de-platformed but i want to go a little
deeper my request for elon musk is this
let's expose all of the algorithms all
of the censorship all of the shadow
banning that has gone on not just for
political leaders like donald trump but
for all the average ordinary everyday
americans and people around the world
especially on the conservative side who
have been censored and shadow banned by
those algorithms i say expose it all so
we know how the narrative has been
messed with and we know how to correct
it for the future i say elon that is
your goal on day one of walking into
that place let's expose twitter tommy uh
i agree with you words i didn't think
i'd be saying this evening but there we
are miracles can happen
uh great to talk to you grace thank you
for joining us we appreciate it